remember that time we like 12 pop-tarts
in one sitting right now oh yeah today
we're trying Jolly Roger flavored
pop-tarts I'm excited to see these two
combos come together Jolly Ranchers and
pop-tarts I used to eat the floors one
the Fenneman one the strawberry one and
of all of them as a kid my teacher you
sit through Jolly Ranchers as like
prizes if you get an answer right I used
to be an avid Pop Tart either like I was
on top of it and like a strawberry
flavor was my jam no pun intended I
already liked the design of the puffed
iron it's so 90s it really is if dr.
Seuss was made into a pastry it's not
like those chewable Jolly Rancher yeah
it sounds good it tastes identical to
enjoyment like super sweet I don't have
to come board for me this is every kid's
dream I like it mm-hmm
I feel like a child eating this and I'm
not afraid to admit that I like it green
apple always a classic oh my god strong
is so strong it's stronger than the
watermelon all right let's try it
hello flower boy sure too much flavor
keeps punching my face and yet I want to
take another bite I have to be in some
kind of mood to want to have this
because it's so sour ten added ten I've
never tasted a pop-tart this good this
is exactly like the Green Jolly Ranchers
this is amazing it's like a valentine
pop-tart I haven't missed the sprinkles
like a traditional mmm-hmm sprinkles out
of all three pop-tarts this is the best
designed pop-tart you can't even talk
about value rentals without at least
talking about sherry come on
[Music]
it's gonna be a hard now tastes like
Valentine's Day
I see like teddy bears and rose petals
and red balloons it doesn't taste like
medicine
yeah doesn't like method it doesn't hate
face this would be good you know take
this on a Valentine's Day breakfast I
think your date with dumped you in a
watermelon took the slice
yes it did the clear winner today if
you're looking for like a deviation from
the typical fruity pop-tarts I'd say
that's the one to go to my favorite one
was cherry because it had the best ratio
of the pop talk to to candy and it hits
at the least fake to me
watermelon was by far the best I would
eat that at home now as an adult
honestly don't try to make watermelon a
pop tart it was good but it wasn't
please bring us Greek bring the grape
and maybe peach and lemon lemon would be
good I think I'd be nice
[Music]
Wow
[Music]